انتقد عضو مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي برني
ساندرز عدم تحرك الكونجرس لوضع حد لمعاناه
الفلسطينيين ومعالجه الكارثه الانسانيه
التي يواجهونها في غزه واضاف ساندرس في
كلمه له امام مجلس الشيوخ ان الولايات
المتحده متواطئه في الماساه التي يعيشها
ملايين
الفلسطينيين هذه الماساه نحن الولايات
المتحده متواطئون فيها الكثير مما يحدث
الان من قصف واعمال اخرى يحدث باسلحه
ومعدات امريكيه بعباره اخرى سواء احببنا
ذلك ام لا الولايات المتحده متواطئه في
الكابوس الذي يعيشه الملايين من
الفلسطينيين ونحن نتحدث
الان
24 الف فلسطيني قتلوا في غزه 70% منهم
نساء واطفال وهناك نحو 60 الف جريح 70% من
المنازل تضررت او دمرت وهناك نحو مليوني
انسان يحاولون النجاه بحياتهم دون توفر
الطعام والماء والدواء والوقود الوضع
الانساني يزداد سوءا كل دقيقه ومئات
الالاف من الاطفال البريئين يواجهون خطر
المجاعه minute